hey Sara button I'm supposed to press
what's happening hey hey do your little
dance again hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to apparition
within the rift an oculus rift horror
game and I have not played an oculus
rift or game in a long time but this one
is supposedly very good now I don't know
too much about that I played my fair
share of bad ones but most of them have
been able to get me in one way or
another so do you want me to play with
the gamepad or not I've got the one that
I broke and I am bread it still works I
did not shatter it completely interact
with okay look at pick up items to go
I'm not even in the game yet bear with
me alright find the jewels collect 20
jewels the a person may notice your
presence escape the house once collected
all jewels four distinct long times will
play exit via side door
I am spitting profusely ensure that
you're wearing the Arkin's headset hello
lantern and press R to reset head
position and start the game okay
BAM oh whoa
holy crap okay it's been a while since I
played the oculus rift or any game on
the oculus rift I forgot how good it can
look oh my god if you've never tried an
oculus rift and you ever get the
opportunity tried especially the new one
with the 1080p screen because it looks
phenomenal
gorgeous terrifying I'm getting serious
Resident Evil vibes from this like the
first one the mansion okay okay so
that's the door with the shields so I'm
on the lookout for 20 jewels why would I
be on the lookout for jewels I'm
something god there's some cool going on
outside there that's so cool
what was that
I heard that okay you can't be [ __ ]
with me this early I just got into it
don't throw me for a loop like I'm a
volume way up god this looks so cool I
want you to bring it on as hard as you
can so that I can crouch [ __ ] poor
pardon me go to hell
okay moving on moving right along
oh are those jewels those look like they
might be jewels can I steal them without
any consequences
that's lamb behind me but I got no
worries or troubles oh man I got gold I
got jewels this is the greatest idea
ever
oh man screw everyone else that died
going into this house I'm gonna be fine
everything's gonna work out for me
alrighty then let's see where it's gonna
go
I can't go behind that door looks like
the doors that glow green I can't
actually open because they probably just
lead out to the environment this looks
really good too it's meat on unity Oh
gold bars absolutely yes I'm about to
get into the thick of it aren't I well
bring on three very off okay all right
then what the hell was that that the
thing same four thumping around upstairs
same four that was in the other game
alright so one of the ghostly
apparitions gonna do huh
I'm seem to be taunting them all they
can do is make the floorboards creak
whoa what was that
okay oh that play billiards can I play
the piano and I sweet I saw something
can I go outside this Ames could be some
really weird green lightning happening
maybe I just took shelter in your room
taking advantage of all the goodies laid
out for me it's not savory I'm an
upstanding citizen I just like shiny
things can you blame me I'm the idiot
that wanders into the stupid [ __ ]
houses not [ __ ] houses whole Rohrer
houses maybe this was but I don't know
that yet I'm not gonna jump to any
assumptions Jim you want to calm down
there a little bit okay no no no no oh
you you you sassy sue huh
want to play with my door huh I'm gonna
come out and deal with you in a second
but first I'm gonna cower like a baby in
the corner that'll show ya I'm brave can
I open these maybe I should just play
off the mouse I don't know fix it no one
behind here huh as I thought looping
door sounds - I suspected as much
this game was gonna meet the standards
that I pride myself in the excellence of
the games that I play oh oh hi what the
hell we're doing huh we gonna do huh
what do you ghostly apparition pull with
your do she's small short legs long arms
blue outline huh look at this what are
you seeing
huh Diouf think I might have encountered
a bug well that it is what it is subs
let him be go on my merry way collect
more jewels and have a happy life what's
that supposed to be there I don't know
why wood means literally just standing
there I don't know
there's a no that's what it's supposed
to do now
now all you vanished
oh hi okay big balls big blue balls
priority alert one big blue ball alert
it's not much more up I can go looking
my lead to the Attic
everyone knows the Attic is a fun place
in horror games Oh No
you've won't open dude cuz I gotta go
back down okay so it said that four
distinct chimes we'll play four distinct
chimes chime each iams III don't think
the gold bar oh [ __ ]
bed blow balls in my fatties
ah you dig back you tea-bagged me
standing up what an a-hole [ __ ] a dog
God my heart I need to recover for a
second bear with me
not many people encounter that on a
daily basis it takes something out of a
man okay that did nothing to help me I'm
still on my own by myself in a haunted
house Oh bad idea probably don't know
any better
I'm dumb dumb play horror games scream
for other people's entertainment it's my
life
dad my life can you not I need to hurt a
noise outside I got a check damn it okay
just how to check heard a noise couldn't
tell if it was in my apartment or
somewhere else
very scary scary Barry skis Barry
putting his jump scare Thank You Barry
someone knocked over this lamp can't
tell who but it's got two great big blue
ball impressions on it very strange Oh
like what's going on in this house
again was this I'm trying to do a thing
impeding the progress I hear some is
that the chime again with the doors
cooled down ha god I missed so many
rooms how many more gems I've got a I've
gotten 20 by now had two toys so many I
could I [ __ ] me
God that it knows the dude coming after
me Jesus oh my heart it's inside the
oculus rift he looks so close it may
seem like he's far away to you but to me
he is immediately there and those balls
are immediately in my face maybe shut up
oh you don't know you don't to me no you
don't know how hot or you think you do
but you do on you think you will but you
warm are you ding dong ding dong hae
young oh I know I know bad bad wait a
minute what the hell you said you let me
go then I got get enough done are given
I got enough you're just being a dick
hello this is a different place very
nice study with fire it's warm and
inviting very counterintuitive to
everything else I've seen so far but who
cares hey walk off with your balls geez
how many times I gotta tell you no means
no hey what the heck was that have I
heard that before
what the hell you son of a biscuit
Nutter what's with these noises now hey
screw you
a lot of gold bars in here get them all
I gotta catch them all apparently got
nothing better to do
I collect every single damn thing in
this house who cares are that ghost once
there you're there I knew you'd be there
you're always there you've always got my
back
you always have always why balls Bing
was that the sound of me being done that
is big for to sigh whoa Jesus thank you
for jumping in front of me credit screen
okay that's the end of it all right all
right well okay just exit oh my god if
you were you just tags an ED what
recording okay hey it's okay all right
Wow
oh that was a bit of a heart attack
there boy itself if you know what I mean
yeah yeah so anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed that that was a lot of fun that
was really involved I mean the scares
weren't that complex but they still got
me just because I was in the Yaquis rift
and they're right next to me and that
right in front of me and they're gonna
kill me but either way that was a lot of
fun so I hope you enjoyed it if you want
to check out there's a whole bunch of
other oculus rift or games that I played
in the past they're all great they all
scare them pants off of me and you will
enjoy them so thanks again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video